it certainly creates a much stronger
conditioning when the reward is or it's
variable unpredictable you want you want
you want a variable reward here it is
right here okay because when that email
goes off you know if it's good or bad
the lottery it's the lottery it's the
slot machine I've got a slot machine in
your pocket I think there are actually
multiple processes involved in what
leads to these unhealthy relationships
with smartphones so there's social
anxiety there's you know our desire for
approval
there's avoidance so when we don't want
to really confront uncomfortable things
that we can use our phones as an escape
all these kind of things were always
with us but this technology is
amplifying all of them most people
especially around here have jobs that
require them to use computers and
computers have now become this force
that is kind of inserted itself into our
lives and we can't extricate ourselves
from it voluntarily there's this
interesting rising tide of hey maybe we
should be teaching ethics maybe we
should be teaching emotional
intelligence and diversity inclusion
equity and you know authentic relating
divergent thinking in addition you're
typing while you're talking to the
patient instead of talking to the
patient there's no eye contact the
entire humanity of the medical discourse
is gone when your child's born with an
iPad rather than your child's born we're
looking at the eyes of other humans
clinical depression is up eighteen point
five percent worldwide Wow four point
four percent of all people on the planet
now carry a diagnosis of clinical
depression
[Music]